protesters at the myanmar embassy in
london where on wednesday night
ambassador chur
min was locked out allegedly by his
deputy and the military attache
last month the ambassador a former army
colonel himself
had broken ranks criticizing the coup on
february the 1st
and calling for the release of the
country's democratic leaders
in the morning he returned and spoke to
reporters outside he said embassy staff
were now
taking orders from the military attache
so is this then the formal
reprisal of the military from your
comments last month do you think
yes the they have instruction from
the capital uh they are obeying their
orders as well this is their decision
he said his own options did not likely
include returning to his country
you want me to see get killed
in what may be one of his last journeys
in an official diplomatic car
chor schwarmin headed to a meeting at
the uk's foreign commonwealth and
development office
in a statement foreign secretary dominic
raab had earlier said
we condemn the bullying actions of the
myanmar military regime in london
yesterday
and i pay tribute to choshua mint for
his courage
the uk continues to call for an end to
the coup and the appalling
violence and for a swift restoration of
democracy
the british government has imposed
sanctions on myanmar military interests
since the coup
but it's not clear what more can be done
now
a foreign office spokesman said
myanmar's military authorities had given
notice
that they terminated the ambassador's
position a decision
the government accepts what is it you'd
like the british government to do sir
open the doors i'll kick them out
yeah yeah joshua says he considers
himself still to be
the ambassador here in london but the
foreign commonwealth and development
office
does not this country has a
long-standing tradition of recognizing
states not countries and so it is the
military in myanmar
that has authority over what happens
inside this building jonah
al jazeera london